Question. Can a lady or woman female
visit a
gynecologist to be examined during this
month Ramadan? For a lady to visit a
gynecologist while she's fasting, it's
not prohibited. But she should take care
that the gynecologist she visits should
be a lady because we have to maintain
the hijab.
It is not advisable or it's rather haram
that she goes to a gent gynecologist
unless there is no one in that area and
she has such a disease which may take a
life or it's a serious case then if she
doesn't find a lady gynecologist and she
goes to a general gynecologist it can be
excused as a last resort but normally
she should visit Lady gynecologist now
when she visits a gynecologist if an
examination is done it may be a PV as we
say in our lingo medical lingo that per
vaginal examin ation whether a finger is
inserted in the vagina that will not
break the fast. If any instrument is put
in the vagina also it will not break any
fast for any testing any examination or
if any vaginal py is also put in in the
vagina that will not break the fast.
While she goes to a
gynecologist, if there are any other
tests done or if any instrument is put
in the uterus, any intrauterine
device or any catheter is put all these
things will not break the fast.
Furthermore, if while the gynecologist
examines her and if any testing has to
be done any tube or cathode has to be
put in the urethra that is urinal
passage all these things will not break
the fast because it does not constitute
that food or nourishment is being
reached and food and nourishment cannot
be given through the vagina through the
urethra through the uterus. So the
scholars are unanimous agree that she
can visit a gynecologist. She can get
herself examined. This will not break
the fast at all.